hi wyatt i'm michelle how are you i'm
i'm amazing
how are you that's the question daddy
how you doing
very good thank thank so much it's it's
incredible
i love seeing that smile on your face
it's it it's a good one
it's a good one how has fatherhood been
treating you everything you hoped it
would be
i think i think it's i think it's
everything you didn't know
i think i think everything you hope is
going to be is like a
mishmash in your mind before it really
happens and then after it happens
whatever happened before is almost it's
like biologically i think it does
something in your brain where you just
erase half your life before you've lived
there and now it's uh
it's about him and your family and
trying to balance
balance everything and time and all that
new new problems and new uh
amazing problems amazing issues to have
or like
you know can't be better your little one
hit the um
grandma and grandpa jackpot i have to
say i want them to be my
grandma and grandpa are they good
they really do are they gonna be grandma
and grandpa or do they have like names
they like
for their grandkids it's starting with
my brothers for for
my sister's first child uh that they're
go go they're go go and gogi my dad's my
dad
his wine that he makes is called gogi
because every
his nickname and life was gogi and my
mom's nickname in life was gogo so
they they uh those those are what the
kids call them that's pretty rad
that's that's pretty cool um so your dad
you know is no
is no um stranger to the mcu and now
you're in uh you're in the marvel family
yourself do you understand now that
you're in it how like
intense the secrecy is and how you
really have to be evolved
yeah yeah it makes it easier
to kind of just when like when you do it
you just try
you i i did it and then tried to just
forget everything
like for real so so i really don't know
the answer to some questions it's like
much easier
to uh to to do it that way
better it is it's like it is like a
fault it's like i always joke i have two
guys with black suits like ready to take
me away at any moment
i don't know how much of a joke that is
if we're being honest i don't know i
know i know
just staying right behind the camera
staring dagger
sam john walker captain america for more
hoskins looks like you guys can use some
help
do you have any nerves about kind of
stepping in and taking over where chris
evans
left off because he was such you know
beloved captain america
um no i mean not really only because
it's different
taking on the role in the first place
was the marvel understanding that like
well why okay this is not i'm not
obviously trying to do
what chris evans did no and you're like
okay great and you kind of
do your own thing and and i think that's
something that is
fun for people to put on it it's really
exciting for people to put
on to the character well you're not that
guy and you're like you know it's kind
of
kind of a point it's like you know it's
kind of what you're playing and it's fun
to be able to
uh i've said it over and over again but
now it is it's like totally it's fun to
be the marvel punching bag for a minute
i get it okay i get the attitude i do
you didn't think
that the shield was gonna end up here i
get it bucky
and i'm i'm not trying to be
steve i'm not trying to replace steve i
was gonna say
you are a bit polarizing right now you
know marvel fans don't play and so there
are some people that are
saying hmm i don't know let me side eye
this man for a second
a hundred percent and you might decide i
you might side the the man for
more to come you might say you know it's
like that's what i liked about the
character
polarizing people are fun to play
they're fun to play as an actor and if
you can do that
and you know do it in a way that is
believable hopefully people really won't
like you and i've never
really played a very unlikable person so
it's
it's been fun it's been super fun i
gotta be honest to be
to have been received that that way in a
way and then there's other times you're
like
i'm a nice guy i'm gonna say do you hear
that marvel twitter
this is on purpose so lean into it
yeah how'd you feel
so we all saw how ripped chris got when
he was playing uh captain america
just how how was this shaping up for
this role and was it like the most
intense
uh working out that that you've done it
was
very different working out that i've
done most intensive work working out
every once when i was playing
sport when i was playing hockey that was
a different that was you had to work out
to actually be good
at something this was like work out to
look good
and and work out too to uh you know feel
like you
you know be in shape and you gotta it is
physical you're
very physical you're in shape for that
and and so that was
of course a big aspect of it i didn't
want to necessarily
look the same so at my regiment may
i might look a little different and
you know i just thought it was
interesting to maybe look a little bit
different
still in shape but not quite as quite as
in shape
we're free agents we're more flexible
so it wouldn't make sense for us to work
with you
a word of advice then
stay the hell out of my way i gotta ask
you about anthony and sebastian because
anthony's a fool and sebastian's just
cool and the two of them together
i mean their chemistry's off the chain
and they're hilarious did you
did you guys have a lot of fun on the
set in between
yeah i said i said to sebastian i was
like
i felt so lucky i texted him one day and
said look i felt i felt very lucky that
i i
was brought into the mcu with you guys
because they're both as good of actors
as they are which
obviously goes without saying nobody
needs to say that about them
they're as nice of people like
they are wonderful people they are
wonderful to be around on set you never
don't want to come to set
because there it's not that's something
that you you don't want to spend your
day there it's
it was lovely and and i had a total
blast with them every time we were
working together
and they're very real people they're
very real people they don't have any
they're not they don't have much facade
to them it's
it was great i can't say good enough
things i don't have the flashiest
gadgets i don't have super strength
but what i do have is guts
something captain america always had
always needs to have and i'm gonna need
every ounce of it
because i got big shoes to film now you
know
usually when a new character is
introduced into the marvel world we do
get them in like little doses maybe here
and there before we get
like their full-fledged story so is
there a world where beyond this series
then we can see you show up
in the movies i don't know you got to
call kevin
dude i don't know
i don't know that's something that
marvel like you're not involved in that
at all you know like that's just
something that
um later on that that becomes a parent
or it doesn't and it has a lot to do
with what fans think i think and how
they feel about you and where they want
to see things go and
that's so far out of my control i just
try to do a good job
and hopefully this this one is good
and it's good enough for them to make
more or
but you know they're those it's above my
[Music]
page
you